nous sommes devant l'assemblée nationale
le là où une dizaine de députés de la
république en marche ont interpellé le
premier ministre dans une lettre que
l'opposition aurait largement pu signer
il tape du poing sur la table
ces députés dénoncent le maintien de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et par le
même de 300 jours de régime d'exception
l'état d'urgence permet l'extension
quasi illimitée des prérogatives de la
puissance publique la réduction
drastique des libertés fondamentales la
liberté doit demeurer en toutes
circonstances le principe et la
restriction l'exception il est de notre
responsabilité de vous alerter sur ce
qui semble constituer à nos yeux un
danger réel pour notre démocratie un
danger réel pour notre démocratie vous
aurez peut-être du mal à le croire mais
les propos sont signés de députés
affiliés à la majorité présidentielle
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
instauré pour la première fois en france
le 24 mars 2020 sur l'ensemble du
territoire suite à la crise lié à
l'épidémie de covin 19
ce régime d'exception elle permet des
restrictions plus étendue que l'état
d'urgence classiques qui visent à lutter
contre le terrorisme
il permet par exemple au préfet de
prononcer des interdictions de sortie
des fermetures d'établissements des
mesures de quarantaine ou des
réquisitions il permet également au
gouvernement de légiférer par ordonnance
c'est à dire sans débat parlementaire
avec la mise en place d' audience à huis
clos et à juge unique en matière pénale
c'est le cas par exemple avec le conseil
d'état qui est devenu l'organe de
décision central du président de la
république
d'autres risques qu'ils soient
sécuritaires sanitaires sociaux
économiques ou climatiques se
succéderont et nous mettrons
collectivement à l'épreuve sans qu'il
soit souhaitable de vivre en permanence
dans un état d'exception justifiée par
l'urgence un état d'exception ne saurait
devenir la règle sauf à dénaturer nos
institutions et porter atteinte au bon
fonctionnement de notre vie démocratique
nous appelons à ce que le bon
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
parlementaire ne devienne pas une
victime collatérale des menaces qui
pèsent sur nos sociétés
les signataires proposent d'inscrire
dans la constitution le régime de l'état
d'urgence
inscriptions qui permettrait d'y
intégrer je cite de solides garde-fous
en matière de protection des libertés
fondamentales
il est nécessaire de définir et
d'expliciter la composition l'émission
les prérogatives et le contrôle des
instances de décision qui comme le
conseil de défense n'ont pas aujourd'hui
d'existence institutionnels ce qui
alimente chez un bon nombre de nos
concitoyens l'idée d'une certaine forme
d'opacité voire de défiance
ces critiques sont depuis des mois
martelait par l'opposition et elles sont
désormais partagés au sein de la
majorité présidentielle
là c'est elle aussi de n'être consulté
que pour la forme
cette prise de position des députés l
air eau m peut surprendre
peut-être faut-il y voir un signe l
approche des échéances électorales